hello everyone and welcome to a very
enjoyable attacking game uh from the
uh from the tiebreaks of the 2022 video
grand prix linear dominguez perez versus
wesley so the first game they played
ended in a draw and this is now the
second game so let's uh let's enjoy that
and the other match is played between uh
uh radoslav tashika and um uh rehab
rapport so we're gonna discuss what
happened in that one maybe i even show
and that one will see how much time i
will have but now let's focus on this
one because it's a really really a wild
one and again it's interesting it
features the uh the joker pianissimo uh
translated from italian that would be
like the the very quiet game or the
quieter game and whenever we see a game
featuring the very quiet or the quieter
game it's it's well pretty much anything
but quiet as you'll see here so uh
linear opens with uh e4 we have e5 by
wesley knight to f3 knight to c6 and
bishop to c4 sorry about that the
italian game is on the board and we have
knight to f6 going for the two knights
defense and now we have d3 uh going into
the so-called modern bishops uh opening
and now bishop to c5 shifting the game
over to the joko pianissimo or the
quieter or the very quiet game so here
white castles black castles and now h3
these are all very very standard moves
nothing out of the ordinary here d6 we
have c3 now preparing to start that
expansion on the queen side and wesley
of course stops this with a5 so rook to
e1 and the bishop to e6 now and here
bishop to b5 it's um
bishop captures and e6 is also playable
for example arunian played this against
the jordan found forest in the magnus
crossing invitational last year and he
won a very nice game but bishop to b5 is
the more standard approach here we have
bishop to a7 and now knight beat the d2
preparing to shift the knight over to f1
and then to e3 g3 depending on what
black plays so knight's the e7 we are
preparing to kick away the bishop with
c6 and now
white strikes in the center with the d4
we have knight to g6 and now usually
white just continues with knight to f1
this is a known possession but here
dominguez goes for a bishop to a4 and it
is now as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game and it is
it is a standard move because black will
always play c6 we're going to move the
bishop but
usually the bishop is moved to d3 but
here it's going to be a little bit
different so now we have knight to h5
wesley wants to get the knight over to
f4 and already it's um
a bit of a different approach because
the bishop is not on d3 so knight to f4
does not come with tempo so knights to
f1 we have knight h to f4 the bishop is
not on d3 so we don't have to react to
this and now just knight the g3
we have c6 now preparing to further
expand on the queen side and the bishop
back all the way to c2
so here queen to d7 now putting a lot of
pressure on that h3 pawn and we defended
with knight to f5 also the bishop from
c2 gives
more more support to the f5 square so
here we have f6 and this is again one of
the uh rare uh occasions where it's okay
to play f6 and bishop to e3 now and what
do you play here well that's the problem
with um a very very analyzed lines like
the the joko pianissimo here it's been
analyzed so much so many uh uh players
that did work on it so many chessable
courses exist on it i think maybe even
wesley made um a adjustable course on
the italian game i'm not sure i mean
pretty much everyone has
now the thing is you have to play d5
here and it's a such a
funny forced line that if you don't play
it you're just gonna be worse or knight
to d5 but d5 i'm just going to show it
because it wasn't played in the game and
it is super fun so the captures on e5
bishop captures an e3 knight captures on
e3 and now f captures an e5 we're going
to play e captures on d5 c captures on
d5 and now bishop captures and g6 we're
gonna play knight captures to defend our
e5 pawn and now knight to g5 go after
the bishop that's also the defender of
the d5 pawn so we're gonna play knight
to f4 to defend our d5 pawn and now
we would probably see something like g3
knight captures knight captures uh on h3
and now we don't have to recapture right
away we can execute the d4 so you can
see it's a very very long forced line
that if you don't know the theory then
you might run into some trouble so here
we would see knight g5 you you will have
to give back one piece for example
captures an e3 rook captures we're going
to see a queen trait captures captures
and now even bishop captures an a2 is
possible and after rook captures on e5
we get this position with equal material
and it's uh well a very drawish droishan
game so that's what you kind of have to
play here but uh wesley played king the
h8 and although it's a very nice
prophylactic move and has many uses it
gives white uh a little bit of extra
time to do what he wanted to do so d
characters on e5 and now if you play d
captures on e5 we can just trade for
example captures captures and bring the
rook into the game with tempo it's not
much but it's uh it's uh
perfectly fine for white so instead
wesley plays f captures on e5 and now
knight the g5 now we are winning the
bishop so d5 wesley pushes d5 now now
knight captures an e6 queen captures
bishop captures an a7 rook captures and
queen to g4 so you can see this position
is a lot more unbalanced than the one
that we've discussed and that's exactly
what uh
what you want also if this knight moves
you're getting checkmated so we we have
to find a way to defend the
uh the pawn now a nice way would be b6
or b5 we expand on the queen side and
also we just defend the g7 pawn with the
rook so that might not be a bad idea
wesley decides to go for queen to f6 uh
defends the pawn this way and also if
the file clears up you have queen
captures on f2 so that's also uh in the
position uh rook 8 to d1 and now h5
wesley kicks away the queen we have
queen to f3 and now queen g5 black also
puts pressure on that um uh g2 pawn and
if you're not careful even knight to h3
might be
a a problem not for the moment the queen
is guarding the h3 pawn but you know
everything is hanging here so queen g3
offering a queen trait can wesley accept
this well if he accepts it captures
captures then what do you do you have to
move the knight for example knight to e6
now he captures on d5 and if c captures
rook captures and it's just a much much
better position for white uh so so much
is hanging here if the knight moves this
knight will be hanging as well so let's
say rook f6 we defend now knight h4 now
let's say knight captures uh here we're
first gonna play rook captures uh on on
e5 now threatening this knight and this
knight and once you play something let's
say you defend this knight we're gonna
play rook captures on h5 with check now
we're gonna pick up the knight and if
let's say rook h6 we're going to play
rook captures rook captures and g
captures an h4 and you get this position
where you're up three pawns in an end
game
and you are of course completely winning
uh so you can't really trade queens here
wesley figures this out he plays queen
back to f6 now comes king to h2
improving the position of the king a
little bit uh and now asking black what
do you what do you play so here rook
back to a8 dominguez wants to activate
this rook somehow we have queen back to
f3 now again there is pressure on that
uh h5 pawn so it's g3 now uh the h3 pawn
is not hanging the king is defending it
we can pick up the h5 pawn so knights
the h4 quickly attacking the white queen
knight captures an h4 queen captures and
now e captures on d5 opening up the
position this way and here wesley plays
uh there there is no better move than
what wesley played you could play knight
captures and d5 but uh then we just go
into queen to queen to d3 and again
white is much much better so wesley
played knight captures on g2 and it
makes sense because if you capture the
knight then rook captures on f2 wins the
queen
and if you capture with the king then of
course we just pick up the queen so
none of this works
so uh linear plays the only move that
works here for white and that is queen
to d3 threatening checkmate on h7 and
now e4
we have to throw in this this one move
uh so if queen captures we can trade
queens so rook captures an e4 is played
but now this gives wesley just enough
time to play queen captures on f2 so now
the rook is blocking checkmate and we
are threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries once we move our knight so
now the position is uh
actually completely winning for uh for
linear so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the only winning
move that wins this for white
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting it as
it's the only move that wins and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is king to h1 that's the good
stuff that's why i like this game so
much because the the only winning move
is sidestepping any discoveries this is
what the dominguez played and now there
isn't really all that much wesley can do
because
uh and just to give you an example uh in
instead of king h1 let's say you play
something like uh
what can you play rookie two okay you're
attacking the queen you're threatening
checkmate seems like you're winning the
problem is knight the e1 you discover a
check and also you are attacking the
queen and yes rook captures uh sorry
rook captures and f2 will be played rook
captures on f2 comes with check and now
after king g1 we play knight captures on
d3 so there is no checkmate bishop
captures on three rook captures on b2
all of a sudden you're down the exchange
is white and you will
lose this game terribly so king to h1
it's the only winning move linear plays
it and now knight to a now
what do you play uh there are no good
discoveries and you know that once the
rook moves uh you are getting destroyed
just rook to e2 now will be sufficient
uh so knights the h4 tries to give back
some material in order to survive rook
captures on h4 now threatening checkmate
and here wesley plays uh g6 uh sort of
hoping for queen captures on g6 maybe
then he's going to be able to stir some
trouble with queen to f3 but linear just
played rook captures on h5 and it was in
this position on move 34 that wesley so
resigned the game and what an incredible
victory for linear dominguez perez uh in
this tie break of the
uh of the of the fiji grand prix so here
you resign because if you capture the
rook then this is just checkmate and if
you don't capture the rook whatever you
play you're still getting checkmated so
whatever you do is checkmate of course
wesley resigned after rook captures on
h5 because it's made in one regardless
of what you play and just so we don't
forget these are now
the pairings for the semi-finals uh
nakamura hikaru will face uh richard
rapport and elevon arunian will face
linear dominguez um
that will be played tomorrow so we are
going to enjoy nice three days of the
semifinals before we see who is in the
finals so what do you guys think uh will
you will we see uh hikaru rapport uh
arunian or dominguez uh in the finals uh
what uh
what do you guys um predict uh so uh
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh another one another very quiet game
that was anything but quiet but they
keep calling it that uh it was called
that you know long long time ago some
500 years ago so yeah we're not going to
hold that against them
so yeah once again hope you guys enjoyed
it i would like to uh thank you god for
making me an atheist john anderson sorry
about that in this position feel free to
pause the video jonathan kemp and fork
entry bu shine tomb i channel for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
grand prix
until it ends so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent start
of your weekend